maintenance automobile réception après
vente les cursus de formation proposés
sur le campus automobile de guyancourt
sont multiples et surtout innovant
ouvert en septembre dernier
l'établissement met donc en avant ses
atouts lors des portes ouvertes
c'est un campus sur lequel vous avez une
offre de formation qui va du ca paix
jusqu'au diplôme d'ingénieur l'objectif
aujourd'hui c'était de montrer ce
qu'était les métiers de l'automobile de
montrer qu'on est sur des métiers de
haute technicité aux technologies de
pouvoir permettre au grand public de
faire des démonstrations de découvrir
les ateliers est de pouvoir alors
démontrer ce que sont les métiers de
l'auto aujourd'hui 380 stagiaires et
apprentis évolué sur le site et le
bouche à oreille fonctionne bien pour
preuve cet étudiant souhaitant se
réorienter sur les conseils d'un de ses
amis
j'ai trouvé ça très très bien parce que
l'école est propre
il ya des bonnes voitures des bons
professeurs franchement j bm est les
portes ouvertes de ce week-end
s'inscrivait dans un contexte de
séduction plus large jusqu'au 23 mars
l'association nationale pour la
formation automobile organise en effet
la semaine des services de l'automobile
et de la mobilité
le secteur recrute chaque année quinze
mille apprentis et 50 mille salariés
dans une centaine de métiers
les débouchés sont donc réelles d'autant
plus que les recherches pour le respect
de l'environnement se multiplient
on notera rien qu'à saint quentin en
yvelines que le secteur de l'automobile
représente au total quatorze mille
emplois et 150 entreprises